hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about a subject that is very
close to my heart perhaps the one thing
besides languages that I get most
interested in along with a few others
but it's the issue of citizenship and
citizenship in a mobile world and I'm
thinking of starting another blog on
this subject and I would like your
advice and opinions i would like advice
on whether i should do the blog in
typepad or if there is some better way
to do it I'm starting to have been
starting to use posterous and I find it
quite convenient but I'm still not very
experienced in this whole you know
setting up of blogs any advice will be
handy and the other thing is just what
you think of the idea now let me explain
what I mean by citizenship and I'm going
to begin by referring to a few things
that I have been commenting on at my
existing blog the linguist on language
and that I have been reading the bug
first of all I commented about an
article that appeared in the local
newspaper The Vancouver Sun by a
professor at the local university
university British Columbia his name was
Henry you he's of Chinese origin
although born in Canada and he
complained that people of Chinese or
Asian origin weren't being promoted fast
enough and God that the city was
increasingly Asian and it wasn't being
recognized and therefore we should have
more Asian languages in our schools and
he of course specifically referred to
Chinese and he seemed to imply that
anyone like him who was born here or who
moved here after the age of 10 and
therefore lost his or her ancestral
language was very unfortunate and his /
zone well leaving aside the fact that if
he wants to learn Chinese he should just
go out learn it like I did but it's the
larger issue of
what does it mean to be say a Canadian
in in this particular instance and
should there be special allowances for
you know people of certain origins
should the the origins or ethnic origins
of people be reflected in you know the
education system and so forth and so on
so so what does it mean to be a Canadian
citizen in in this situation so that was
one since this situation that was this
article that appeared and I I answered
him and that was also printed in The
Vancouver Sun and both those articles
can be found at my blog another sort of
interesting situation is the one that's
developing in the Ukraine or Ukraine as
the now call themselves not the Ukraine
where you have sort of a western part of
the Ukraine which historically was part
of Poland or the austro-hungarian Empire
or whatever and the eastern part which
has you know stronger Russian
connections both both you know under I
just as ours period and even under the
Soviet period a lot of people from
Russia emigrated down there a lot of the
Ukrainians who live there speak Russian
more than they speak Ukrainian but and
so you have the sort of internal divide
within Ukraine between the west and the
east which is reflected in the recent
presidential election but at the same
time even those predominantly
russian-speaking Ukrainians still
identify as Ukrainians and yet they're
not that much different from the
russian-speaking Russians just across
the border in the eastern part of
Ukraine I mean we could say the same
about Switzerland Germany Austria where
they all come together those people are
historically the same tribe if you want
I'm reading a book on the history of
Scotland and I guess was 1707 or
whatever Scotland voted to form a union
with england because there were a lot of
commercial advantages but of course it
was a very controversial decision
somewhere for some were against and so
you've had sort of an ebb and flow of
Scott
a nationalist feeling one of the
interesting things is from this book it
turns out that many of the trappings of
what it is to be Scottish like the kilt
and and you know the Highland warrior
image that in fact for the longest time
the Highlanders were looked down upon by
the low lenders who are far more
numerous and yet all of a sudden their
clothing and their customs are
identified as national symbols and in
fact the Highlanders were I think
predominantly Catholic for a long time
and so there's all kinds of religious
you know Protestant Catholic rivalry
going on and what's more a lot of those
Highland Scots actually emigrated over
from Ireland in earlier history and yet
out of all of that you have the sense of
Scottish citizenship and one of the
interesting things to in this book they
mentioned the fact that there was this
dramatic increase in emigration from
Europe in the latter half of the 19th
century 44 million people left Europe
the left countries obviously from Spain
they went to Latin America from I gather
places like Ireland Scotland and Norway
had a very had the highest percentage of
people leaving like 1,000,000 out of
five or something oh twenty percent
emigrated so and then of course from
Eastern Europe people emigrated and so
forth why did they emigrate because all
of a sudden there was steam ship travels
so so the interesting phenomenon again
is that the world became more mobile and
a very high percentage of people who
emigrated eventually went back to their
country of origin so you know something
like thirty forty fifty percent people
from Scotland or other countries
emigrated to the United States or Canada
and half of them are thirty forty
percent of them went back home again so
we have the sense of mobility well the
world is much much more mobile today and
people can stay in touch with their
culture of origin much more easily they
can move around much more easily and so
all of this then brings
question what are the responsibilities
of citizenship and here in canada we
have a government that has taken the
Ministry of multiculturalism and changed
it into the Ministry of multiculturalism
added merged with the citizenship
ministry and they've published a sort of
a citizenship guide and they're trying
to move the sense of multiculturalism
which was the politically correct
position here the one that is still
promoted in our universities and schools
and that is that the more varied we are
the better everybody's culture is good
we don't have one so whatever strange
customs people have when they come here
that those should be respected and have
pride of place here now people are begin
to realize that there is a limit to this
that you know there are some customs in
some countries that we're just not going
to accept so once we've understood that
there's a limit to what we will accept
you know it could be a female
circumcision it could be eating dogs it
could be any number of things then we
begin to sort of back away and and we
also notice that there are people who
come to Canada for example and who
maintain a loyalty to their country of
origin or to some other ideology like a
religion for that matter and that this
other attachment whether it be to Serbia
China Israel Islam Sri Lanka whatever it
might be this seems to take precedence
over their attachment to Canada now from
the perspective of a country like Canada
if you have ten fifty percent of the
population who are more attempt to some
other place it's probably not a big deal
but as we have more and more immigration
it begs the question what if we end up
with a country where everybody is more
attached to somewhere else and so the
whole question of citizenship in in a
mobile world is the one that I want to
start talking about and writing about
and getting on videos and and to have as
a subject of discussion to get views
about and and if people are interested
in this for
or their English learning and I could do
some in other languages in French but
I'm not a native speaker of those other
languages and perhaps put out
transcripts and and so we can have a
lively discussion on this subject and at
the same time generate some content
which could be useful for those of you
who are learning English so let me know
whether you think this would be of
interest obviously we would attract a
whole new I hope to attract a whole new
set of listeners and readers I would be
writing I would be recording art making
be making videos let me know if you
think it's a good idea if you're
interested and also any advice on what
format for my blog typepad or otherwise
and the share between simply text that I
write verses podcasts that I record
verses videos so I'm looking for advice
and comment thank you for listening bye
for now